ce n'est pas un être humain c'est
un fléau de la nature
j'ai été retenu captif pendant 12 ans
sous réserve de m'échapper quelque part dans le
bâtiment les
humains chassent les lycans et les vampires
c'est
une nouvelle guerre
j'avais l'habitude d'entendre des histoires sur les chefs de la mort
mais ils étaient une chose  du passé
pour ne jamais revenir,
je ne reconnais pas ce monde,
nous vivons en sécurité depuis des années et maintenant
vous avez amené les humains dans cette alliance,
nous sommes debout et nous combattons
quelque chose d'autre échappé,
quoi qu'il en soit, il est plus puissant que n'importe lequel d'entre
nous
Michael
You